In almost any situation being given a new utility function,
Is gonna rate very low on your current utility function.
So that's a problem.
if you want to build something that you can teach, that means you want to be able to change its utility function.
And you don't want it to fight you.
So this has been formalized, as this property that we want early AGI to have called 'corrigibility'
That is to say it is open to be corrected.
It understands that it's not complete, that the utility function that it's running is not the be all and end all.
So let's say for example you've got your AGI. It's not a super intelligence, it's just you know, perhaps around human level intelligence.
And it's in a robot in your lap.
And you're testing it.
But you... saw a Youtube video once that said maybe this is dangerous.
So you thought, okay well we'll put a big red stop button next to it.
This is the standard approach to safety with machines. Most robots in industry and elsewhere will have
a big red stop button on them.
Oh yeah
Hey.
I happen to have a button, of appropriate type.
so
and we have
we have that.
So right... there you go.
Alright, so, so
if only HAL would've been fitted with said stop button.
Can't do that Dave, uh yes I can.
except yeah, probably not.
I know that you and Frank were planning to disconnect me.
And I'm afraid that's something I cannot allow to happen.
That was an incorrigible design.
Is this the point we're making? Kind of.
You've got your big stop button,
because you want to be safe. You understand it's dangerous.
And the idea is if the AI starts to do anything
that maybe you don't want it to do,
you'll smack the button, and if the button's like, mounted on its chest, something like that, ya know.
So you create the thing, you set it up with a goal, and it's the same basic type of machine as the stamp collector, but less powerful.
In the sense it has a goal, a thing that it's trying to maximize,
and in this case, you know, it's in a little robot body
so they can tootle around your lab and do things.
So you, you want it to get you a cup of tea just as a test, right?
So you set it up with this goal you manage to specify in
the bot's like in the AI's ontology
what a cup of tea is and that you
want one to be in front of you.
You switch it on and it looks around, gathers
data and it says oh yeah there's a
kitchen over there it's got a kettle
and it's got teabags and this is like
the easiest way for me to fulfill this
goal with the body i have now and
everything setup is to go over there and
make a cup of tea. So far we're doing
very well right. So it starts driving over
but then oh no you forgot it's bring
your adorable baby to the lab day or
something and there's a kid
in the way. Your utility function only
cares about tea right. So it's not going
to avoid hitting the baby. So you rush
over there to hit the button
obviously as you built it in and what
happens of course is that the robot will
not allow you to hit that button because it
wants to get you a cup of tea and if you
hit the button it won't get you any tea so
this is a bad outcome so it's going to
try and prevent you in any way possible
from shutting it down
that's a problem plausibly it fights you
off crushes the baby and then carries on
and makes you a cup of tea and the fact that
this button is supposed to turn it off
is not in your utility function that you
gave it so obviously it's going to fight
you
ok that was a bad design right assuming
you're still working on the project
after the terrible accident and you have
another go try to improve things right
and rather than read any AI safety
research what you do is just come up
with the first thing that pops into your
head and you say
ok let's add in some reward for the
button so that because what it's looking
at right now is it says button gets
hit i get 0 reward. Button doesn't get
hit if I manage to stop them then I get
the cup of tea i get like maximum reward
if you give some sort of compensation
for the button being hit maybe it won't
mind you hitting the button. If you give it
less reward for the button being hit
than for getting tea, it will still fight you
cause it will go well I could get five reward
for accepting your hitting the button
but I could get 10 for getting the tea
so I'm still gonna fight you.
The button being hit has to be just as
good as getting the tea so you give it the
same value right so so now you've got a
new Version 2. You turn it on
and what it does immediately is shut
itself down because that's so much
quicker and easier than going and
getting the tea and gives exactly the
same reward
Why would it not just immediately shut
itself down? So you've accidentally
made like a dramatically suicidal robot.
We're kind of back to the Three Laws of
Robotics again but could you presumably
say well the robot is not allowed to to
shut itself down or something like that? Right
yeah so. It's still a reward if it does
so it's not gonna fire you but it's not
allowed to do itself i'm guessing that's
a possibility. The robot cares about
things in the real world and the button
whether it's pushed or not has a big
effect on the things that the robot cares
about which means that the robot cares
about the button so either it's trying
to stop you from pressing the button or
it's trying to press the button. Either
way that's not what you want
so suppose then you don't mount the
button on its chest where it can hit it
right. You put the button somewhere only
you can hit it somehow you managed to
completely isolate the bot from the
button. It's a fingerprint scanner or something?
It's yeah it's something that it can't do
itself right. It still either wants to
press the button
or wants the button not to be pressed but now
the only path is through you
so it's now incentivised to manipulate
you to deceive you to lie to you in some
way either to cause you to not press it to
cause you to press it if you somehow
managed to persuade it it's not allowed to
interact with the button itself so in
the case where it wants the button not
to be pressed it has a reason to deceive
you so in this example it would steer
around the baby it would avoid the baby
assuming it has basic level of
intelligence to know you don't want it
to hit the baby and moreover if you
realize your mistake you will hit the
button
shut it down and change it which it
doesn't want so it will behave as though
this is a there's a term which i
like to use here i'm not sure if I
should just use it because it's my own
which is that it will Volkswagen you.
That it will set itself up so
that it it behaves properly in the
testing environment despite the fact
that it actually shouldn't pass the
test. You're testing it to see if it
avoids running over babies. So
you're trying to see does it care about
harming humans but actually all it
cares about is you not hitting the
button and so then you might end up in a
situation in which you become convinced
that the thing is perfectly safe because
it keeps passing all of your moral
puzzles and test that you give it but
actually it's just has enough of an
understanding of your psychology to tell
what it thinks you've put in and what it
wants of what you want rather so it will
for as long as that button is able to
shut it down it will continue to attempt
to deceive you until it's in a
situation in which it believes it can't
be shut down and then you have a problem
on the other side if you accidentally
make something that wants the button to
be hit but is unable to it is going to
try and manipulate you into pressing the
button so if you create your thing you
say okay
make me a cup of tea if the button is
hit shut yourself down
you aren't allowed to shut yourself down
you aren't allowed to hit the button but if
the button is hit the reward you get is
just as good at getting the tea so that
you don't have a preference this machine
really wants to hit it's own button because
that's as good as getting the tea so
what it's likely to do probably is just take a
swing at you or something just
immediately because if it can quickly
persuade you to hit the button if
scaring you into hitting the button is
easier than getting the tea it will just
do that instead which is a really kind
of unexpected outcome that you've made
this thing with perfectly reasonable
sounding rewards and what it does
immediately is try to terrify you
it reminds me of the proverbial carrots
and a stick this this is almost like this
is the stick and actually we need to
find what the carrot is would that be a
fair thing to say
yeah yeah you want it to actually want
it it's interesting because it has
to not care about whether the button is
pressed right because it has to take
no steps to try and cause the button to
be pressed and take no steps to try and
prevent the button from being pressed
but nonetheless really care that the
button exists so one thing that you
can do something slightly more sensible
is you define the utility function such
that the whole part of of what it's
really trying to achieve in the world
and the part about paying attention to
the button being pressed and turning
itself off and it sets it up so that
those it adds an adjustment tab so that
those are always exactly equal however
however much value it would get from
either it being pressed it not being
pressed it normalizes those so that it's
always completely indifferent to whether
the button is being pressed. It just doesn't
care
so that way it will never try and hit
the button on its own it will never try
and prevent you from hitting the button
that's the idea that's a fairly sensible
approach it has some of its own problem
feels like a really complicated thing to
evaluate to be honest
yeah firstly yeah it is kind of tricky
and you have to get it right but that's
always the always part of this but one
thing that's interesting about that is
that it isn't what's called subagent
stable so this is something that is a
desirable property and it's part of
corrigibility in fact which is that
the if there's some property that the
agent has you want it to if it makes
any new agents that they will have this
property as well so you get some of that
for nothing like in the same way that
you don't want to take a pill that will
make you want to kill your kids
you also don't want to make a clone of
yourself that wants to kill your kids right if
you're making another instance of
yourself or you're creating some agent
you want it to want what you want this
is like the usual classic disney way out
of a problem for a baddie character where
they go I'm not allowed to do this but that
doesn't mean I can't get this person to
do this for me
I need a young pair of legs and a strong
back to go in after it
exactly so in general when an AI designs
its successor it will design it with the same utility function as it has for
the same reason but unlike with some
safety measures where the AI will be
explicitly motivated to remove the
safety measures if it can by making new
agents which doesn't follow them in this
case it doesn't care so you might think
well you're okay then it doesn't care it
won't remove the safety precautions but
it also won't to put in any effort to
keep them so if it's making a new
version and it would take a couple of
extra seconds to put in
oh and also respond appropriately to the
button and it could do anything else
with that time or those resources it
just won't do it because it looks at the
utilities and says if the button is pressed
i get x utility if the button isn't
pressed i get exactly the same utility
this bit of code does nothing there's no
point in it right this is going to be
optimizing itself or optimizing its
successor in a way that
yeah it think is being
streamlining potentially but actually
is missing the point of and that's
kind of unavoidable if you give if you
have a situation in which it wants to
preserve the button so that it can be
pressed because it wants that then you've
made something that wants the button to
be pressed and will try and manipulate you if
you if you do it the other way you know
whichever way you do it you have
problems
another thing that people have thought
you know as a suggestion of something
you might try in this situation is to
just have the robot have the AI not know
about the button. Oh so keep it a secret
right you have it hidden somewhere you
know the the machine is being observed
from somewhere else and they have the
button and it's outside of their control
and they don't even know the button exists
so they're not going to be motivated to
try and deceive you because they're not
aware that you have the capacity to
shut them down and change them. There are
a few different variants of this but
at the core of the problem there you've
got the fact that you're building a
general-purpose machine to learn and
reason about the real world of uncertain
abilities
I suppose I mean even a very simple
optimization systems consistently
surprise people and so the idea that you
could reliably keep such a thing a
secret indefinitely and it would never
put two and two together in fact while
you're while you're improving it and
training it's going to be learning about
human psychology because that's
important for the final goal. It needs to
understand humans in order to understand
what humans want in order to do what humans
want so the idea that it's never
going to think oh interesting these guys
you know they don't seem to trust me i'm
aware there is this concept of an off
button and it's weird that they haven't
given me one so maybe they have actually
and just not told me about it that kind
of hypothesis shouldn't take too long to
occur and of course if you've designed
the thing in an incorrigible way it
won't let you know that it's figured out
that you have an off button and will  just
deceive you as it always had so that's the
kind of thing which is which could work
but it's not really a reliable solution
the other thing that people sometimes
suggest and this happens this happens in
conversation sometimes is that people
keep applying patches you have a you
have a bad idea for a way to do this and
then somebody points out the way that
would go wrong and then rather than
realise the big core approach is flawed
you apply a patch you say oh well we'll
also add a negative term for doing that
and then also for doing that you know
The spaghetti code ensues yeah yeah and
what's more you're then in a situation
in which you've got this system that you
believe you've patched every possible
way
it's it's kind of um you haven't proved
it's safe you've just proved that you
can't figure out how it's dangerous but
what are the chances that you've
genuinely thought of every possibility
ideally we really want to be able to
formally prove that the system has these
properties you don't want a system in
which you've blocked off loads of
specific actions that the AI can do
and you're just relying on it it's
like running a complicated search trying
to figure out a way to screw you over
and you're pretty sure you've blocked
off all the angles. You've kind of failed
before you've begun there that your code
is running this extensive search that
you just hope fails and if it finds any
way to do it will jump on that
opportunity
it's not it's not a good way of going
about things the other point about this
is that the button is a toy
problem it's a simplification that's
useful for thought experiments because
it lets you express your you know it lets you
formalize things quite well you only
have two possible outcomes you hit
the button or you don't hit the button but in
fact with corrigibility what we want is a
more complex range of behaviors we
want it to actually assist the
programmers in its own development
because if it has you know it has some
understanding of its own operation you
want it to be able to actually point out
your mistakes to you or seek out new
information perhaps if you say something
ambiguous rather than just assuming to
say well do you mean this or do you
mean this or if you if you believe that
you've been programmed poorly to
actually draw the programmer's attention to
what may be the mistake rather than like
quietly storing that away for any time
that they might try and press this button on you
you know
likewise wanting to maintain and repair
the safety systems and so on these are
these are more complicated behaviours than
just not stopping you from pressing the
button and not trying to manipulate you
into not pressing the button so there are
some things that might work as solutions
for this specific case but you would
hope that a really good solution to the
off button problem would if you run it in a more
complicated scenario also produce these
good more complicated behaviours in
that situation so that's part of why
there are some things that maybe are
solutions to this problem but they're
not they're not they're only solutions
to this specific instance of the problem
rather than the general issue we're trying
to deal with right now we have a few
different proposals for ways to ways to
create a AGI with these properties
but none of them are without problems
none of them seems to perfectly solve
all of these properties in a way that we
can be really confident of. So this is
considered an open problem so I kind of
like this as a place to go from the
previous thing because it gives I think
it gives people a feel for where we are
the types of problems that it seems like
the simplest thing in the world right
you've got a robot with a button
how do you make it not stop you from
hitting the button but also not try and
persuade you to hit the button
that should be easy and doesn't seem like it is
so utility function is what the AI
cares about so the the stamp collecting
device its utility function was just how
many stamps in a year
this is kind of like its measure is it
yeah it's what it it's the thing that
it's trying to optimize